countryroads days ago
it's me Mario mushroom kingdom
[Music]
we're welcome everyone that's the sound
of special news reporter it's me Gloria
Borger here for special news report an
announcement meme related an egg has
overtaken Kylie Jenner as the most liked
Instagram post ever that is crazy I know
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but
Wow an egg can you imagine getting
beaten by an egg now the most liked now
the most liked picture Instagram is an
egg everybody pat yourself on the back
you did it 26 million likes let's set a
world record together and get the most
lag post on Instagram being the current
record Kylie Jenner I bet you how to
basic is just shaking right now
he's like why did I not think of that I
think the verge posted this the best
what a time to be alive an egg picture
gets the most likes what a time to be
alive
this is crazy an egg an egg unfreaking
egg are you kidding me I'll let you post
give my prayers but gotta crazy
Kylie Jenner had the best response
I mean her response was stop I was like
I can't wait to see Kylie Jenner's
reaction to this
I bet she's gonna have the right thing
to say to just make everyone go whoa
take that little egg really hot
she reposted someone else's me Kylie
Jenner I challenge you fight me next
tank I'm not afraid to hit a child how
about how about Kylie Jenner vs. PV pipe
like this egg that's all you had to say
so an egg is now the most like picture
in instagrams history how excellent is
this kind of things that just makes me
want to not live just this is the reason
why I can't be enthusiastic about things
just stop this is brilliant
but I like this I'm giving the egg me
man an egg 26 billion of them that's a
lot of eggs now we can only get all
those eggs to subscribe to PD by then we
can be t-series eggs I'm calling upon
all eggs you subscribe to Felix we can
beat all kylie jenner's sorry I don't
like how to basic what other motives do
you need subscribe my eggs my fellow
eggs I call upon thee in the time of
great danger
subscribe to PvP next me we got that
uh-huh
what you got there smoothie get it
because he's holding a smoothie now
people made a different version of this
means ah what you got there
what you got there yeah what are you
smoothie no you're not you're holding a
tick tock tock and it's movie yeah
smoothie
you guys seen this is it just me is it
just me or is my G wait can I drink
myself is that even possible
[Music]
what you got there know what Julie cop
huh what you got there
typical American just a gun kinder egg
surprise this is crazy I just found this
out in America kinder egg surprises is
unlegal did you guys even have a
childhood s MH pathetic hey you know
it's not a meme until someone makes a
world war two joke
Hiroshi Shima yes that's how it felt
Nagasaki um what you got there
USA two atomic bomb smoothie so that's
how they did it
what another new era burger here again
for another meme review news this is it
boys we have found big chunga's IRL
karen changose junga junga junga junga
junga junga karen chunga's is a real
person that people discovered on
facebook
do you hear that she's an ant-heap of
course yes of course she's hectic backs
mother of two beautiful children who are
unvaccinated not only does Karen
chunga's his name chunga she looks
identical to big chunga's are you guys
hearing that or what I'm not supposed to
give my opinion but do you guys hear
that sound level one crook
level hundred mafia boss Karen changose
junga junga junga junga junga junga
I swear this is next name this is not
even a mean I'm just reviewing this so
you guys will stop sob obsessing over
every single girl that appears on
tick-tock everyone's reposting this girl
dancing to that weather scooby-doo we've
come in after you forgot a song man
mystery way scooby-doo listen we already
had the hit or miss Crais I don't want
another one just please guys stop find a
girl
IRA okay stop being such a loser and
obsess over tick-tock girls just stop
it's not gonna go anywhere she just
wants you for likes and clouds she
doesn't want you for you're nothing you
got nothing to offer either I don't know
all that tastes good G fuel TD pie
flavor
thanks Phillies James charts
you guys heard about this you guys know
about this James Charles everyone's
favorite beauty fashion guru blogger
makeup person James Charles which we all
thought we knew transforms however at
night into a dark creature
James Charles is in every horror movie
ever how could we have been so blind no
sister bye sister oh my gosh it's pretty
pie yes anything can become a meme in
2018-19 whatever year it is chad has
just called out one of the prisoners to
make contact with him alright I'm tired
of this James Charles is in every horror
ever I just want to play a nice little
game like Minecraft okay peaceful
difficult maybe I'll step it up a little
[Music]
damn it god damn it James Charles I had
enough for you gems choice Dean James
choice tight okay it's my no oh no oh no
[Music]
this has been the saddest meme review so
long maybe we have time for bonus it's
worth a shot
what they calling on Brad Brad
do we have time for bonus me only if you
enter the code PewDiePie and bite all
the GPL stuff for 30% off which
technically means you can't just buy 30%
more you can actually buy 42.9% more is
that what you said show bonus meme oh my
god I thought bonus me was dead this
only happens once every comet sunshine
four okay what did we catch sir the
price is $10 but we'll charge five
dollars more for shipping no that's too
much okay $15 price with free shipping
that's all you had to say this every
meme in 2019 have to have some sort of
racially undertone to it I like it
keep it up huh wanna come over to ah him
no go away
her we can watch Star Wars Episode three
Revenge of the sick afterwards that's
all you had to say I really want to say
the n-word not because I want to say the
n-word but because I'm racist when the
skippable ad says wait wait don't skip
this edge I saw you had say I love this
mean it's beautiful EA we change the
number of the undercover that's all you
had to say I'll buy another one get it
FIFA fans
you're stupid they're just changing the
number of the cover they're not changing
anything else it's the same with the
Apple fans oh hey look we have the same
product just a hundred pounds more
expensive that's all you had to say mum
finish your vegetables I don't want to
finish your vegetables or no dessert
what that's all you had to say there's a
count if you read it in your head right
Anakin is it possible to learn this
power Senate not
today Anakin that's all you had to say
hey look here this Apple we added
another hundred dollar to the price tag
Apple fans hold on this whole operation
was your idea
oh I love this this is so great when
your teacher calls on you to read the
page in AD how to kill a mockingbird
with the n-word but you read it with too
much enthusiasm and get a detention hold
on
this whole operation was your idea
bonus bonus me we did it guys
we absolutely did it this means t-series
is destroyed this means no more
controversies this means you have to
smash like on this video by the merch
and check out gfu link in description
sponsored video down below thank you
guys go and live a life go and live a
happy life
bonus bonus me Jesus Christ I'm just
gonna I'm gonna I have to go I have to
tell someone you want pyramids we got oh
oh you're into castles huh we got you
covered baby you want some bets easy we
got it all this game is still relevant
god damn it